[Music]
awesome all right welcome everyone to
another lecture
um okay today I'll be showing
several or maybe only one best game I
have played in my life in the London
opening and uh the London has been super
popular lately you have been probably
seeing it like all around the place and
um it's just a nice kind of lazy way of
playing with the white pieces but if you
know how to play it well I think you can
definitely make it a a big deal so and
this is also my best win of my career so
far
so it should be interesting in my
opinion so combining one of my favorite
openings one of the lazy openings with
my best win I think is the best way to
go so okay
for those who do not know the London
opening starts with D4 Knight F6 Bishop
F4 so a slight backstory to this game
this was played in the Turkish League
and I was playing for the board one
of my team
and um
so
I usually play like E4 or D4 or anything
of that sort and I was really having a
tough time sort of preparing against my
opponent since he's super experienced uh
above 2700 before Grandmaster European
Champion so he has a lot of experience
against E4 D4 in any opening actually
so during the lunch time I go up to one
of my teammates he's actually he plays
the London for his whole life and I'm
like what would you recommend like what
shall I do and I actually know the
answer he's gonna say the London I just
wanted to justify my take of playing the
London so he's like yeah just go play
London and then I'm like okay so
somebody else recommends it so I'll just
play the London so basically I did some
prep and it was tough to guess what my
opponent's gonna do I was just in a more
calm mindset just to play something and
get out of the opening and just see how
it goes so he goes E6 E3
um
C5 Knight D2 just normal developing
moves Knight C6 Knight F3 D5 C3 so we
get like one of the most Mainline
positions of the London
um of course there are other lines too
which I'm not gonna like go too much in
detail but of course my opponent could
have played anything else but he played
this line at that point this is like
2018
he played the CD 484 Knight h51 and this
was a big Theory back then it still is
it's one of the most played responses
from the black side of course the main
line probably is Bishop D6 where white
usually goes Bishop back to G3
white can castle and then here white
sorry black and castle and white has
like two moves Bishop B5 or Bishop D3 so
it's up to you basically what you want
to do and then the whole point of let's
say something like Bishop D3 is to go
like Queen E2 and then like E4 so try to
attack on the king side somehow this is
how our perspective and this is what
we're trying to do with white
um of course we would be happy if our
opponents ever takes on G3 because we
take out the H Pawn and we have this
massive attack on H7 so black players
usually don't do that they try to do
other things but um that's not how the
game went so I'm not gonna make you guys
lose too much time I'll show you the fun
part so i c d e d Knight H5 here once
again we have I believe multiple moves
Bishop G5 and Bishop E3
at that time my preparation was Bishop
E3 so I applied that in Bishop D6 so
what does black want black is saying
okay I'm just gonna develop and if you
ever go something like Bishop D3 I'm
gonna jump Knight F4 attack your Bishop
attack your pawn and you do have to give
up your
um
dark Square Bishop so after this take
sticks this is probably good for black
so what I did still in my prep I played
this move 95. so what's the idea of
Knight E5
at this moment I am attacking the Knight
on H5
and I'm also maybe putting some pressure
here and definitely blocking this bishop
so there is no Knight of four jumps
right so the trick is if black takes on
E5 with the Knight I can simply go D
takes E5 now I'm attacking this guy and
that guy and you cannot defend one of
the pieces so you lose the game
so instead if you take with the bishop
for example
now I can take the bishop and now your
knight is kind of stuck even though you
can go G6 or something like this
your um
not losing a piece you're just not doing
great because you gave up your dark
Square Bishop so what they often played
and that's what my opponent played is
the move G6 so he's defending the
um
he's defending his Knight and attacking
my knight on E5
so here multiple moves there's this move
F4 which is not bad
and there is this move which I played
Knight F3 defending the Knight
and in this moment my opponent played
the move
F6 attacking my
my knight here
so this is probably the first critical
moment because my opponent was
definitely in his prep so he knew what
he was doing kind of
and I was trying to remember what I did
here but
I couldn't exactly remember I played the
move very quickly actually and that's
after that moment my opponent started
thinking and spending a lot of time so
I'm gonna ask the viewers actually
um on what they think
the move should be
in this position
there is in-person attendance there's
online attendance I think yep
the
the twitch chat is smart
so they're recommending this move G4
but I want to leave this Knight hanging
and yeah if you have seen my games a
little bit so if you were here in any of
the streams before you know that I like
to sacrifice things I like to give
pieces for free I mean of course there's
an idea behind it usually but
um
yeah so Knight takes C6 would be the
most logical move but after B takes I
wasn't really having it because
um Black's gonna go E5 next move and
this is not going to be great so here I
played actually the move G4 attacking
the Knight so okay this is not really
what we teach when we start playing
chess don't like push your pawns but
again the idea is like if you get to a
certain level and you're like a grand
master it's also very important to know
when you should break the common rules
because if you played every move just by
the book then there will be no
difference everyone's gonna play well so
G4 is um
the move I played my opponent played
Knight back and here I took the Knight
and played this move H4 so all of this
makes sense I am kind of attacking on
the flank there is nothing
hanging but in this moment my opponent
played the move E5
and now this is where the fun begins
because
they are attacking
our
Pawn
and we have to do something about it
so and someone is asking on the YouTube
chat is this live this is live yeah this
is very live
in person live on YouTube live on Twitch
so
what do we do opponent is attacking
opponent is attacking our Pawn
it's not a replay no
someone is saying Rook over
look over I guess this one someone is
saying push the pawn but guys we have
seven Pawns
if you say push the pawn I can
understand this or I can understand that
or this or this or that there's a there
are plenty of Pawns
so which pawns are which Pawn are we
talking
at some point it will be a replay yes
G5 yeah G5 is the most tempting move
probably right because it's being
attacked well one of the problems with
G5 is our opponent can jump their Knight
to this Square so for example if I go G5
my opponent might respond with something
like E4 attack this Knight and then I
have to go back at some point although I
can probably take here and then they
take it's also possible I would say like
I can jump 95 maybe with the idea to
give up this Knight so this looks like a
free Pawn right take take and take but I
would rather have the dark Square
control here than have this Pawn but I
don't think anyone's gonna take this
Knight they might just jump like Knight
here or something I'm not sure it's just
quite annoying with how this night came
from G7 to F5 and it might land on E3
and
not really what I wanted to do
so
I didn't play G5
let's see who can calculate because I
mean you can see the move you can find
the move but calculating the move and
understanding is it actually quite
difficult knowing it and seeing it in
the computer is one thing but
understanding how difficult it is is
something else so DTX E5 being suggested
well I don't really want to take because
after takes then they're gonna take on
G4 so it's quite annoying actually to to
give up
um
this Center like that so I don't want to
do that I don't want to give my opponent
the center while I control nothing of it
all right so what else let me see the
chat
G5 we talked the E5
yeah so none of that
it's it's kind of a
it's kind of a difficult move I would
say if
you can calculate a little bit far
and you're not sure of what's happening
when I played it my opponents spent a
lot of time like I was actually up a lot
of time as soon as this position arrived
like E5 I made a move I had like over 1
hour 30 minutes which is the starting
time and my opponent was just losing all
his time he was spending a lot of time
Bishop H3 no G5 is not that great here I
played the move H5 I sacrificed
my Pawn on G4
but this is actually
a very challenging move to make I would
say because
it hangs the pawn
on G4
and
what happens if Bishop takes G4
the idea is actually to take on G6
but in this position my opponent can
play the move E4
which I would actually is what happened
in the game I played them of H5 my
opponent played E4
and here I actually ignored it and I
took the
I took the pawn on G6 I sacrificed my
knight and my idea is that if you take
my knight
I'm gonna take on H7
and then if you take or something I'm
going to take back I'm threatening to
promote and remember this is just the H
Pawn that went all the way to H7 and
it's about to promote and let's say my
opponent stops promotion with something
like King F7 now I take here I have like
multiple pawns
um let's say this one too which is a
different one I have multiple pawns for
my opponent's extra Knight
but his King is also not safe and I'm
gonna finish my development develop my
Bishop bring the rook in and I'm gonna
try to go after his King and most likely
he's not going to be able to complete
any of his peace development and he's
gonna get mated very soon because
although you're up an extra piece extra
piece is useless if you cannot utilize
your extra piece so
I'm all about initiative and attack and
everything even if it's in the sake of
giving up a knight or something that is
totally fine as long as the attack has a
purpose and the purpose can be achieved
without giving up
everything that's you can give up
everything as long as you don't lose the
game so
yeah it is quite an actually it's one of
my best games so maybe one of maybe the
best I don't know so my opponent played
Bishop G4 this is where the tricky part
is
um like seeing this in advance because I
cannot move this Knight like he's not
gonna give me this opportunity of uh
picking up this Pawn on F3 too so that's
why when I played H5 my opponent was
like At first surprised right
um
they they just like took a second
they're like okay it's just a free piece
and then they notice it's actually not a
free piece so how does the line go here
Rook H7 yeah that's definitely the move
I want to play right but what happens
after let's say my opponent takes takes
and then moves the king let's say to F7
so they are preventing promotion with
the queen so what do I do here
and imagine you see this from a distance
this is where the trick actually becomes
because if you don't see it from a
distance then it's like not that
important not not that impressive
because I'm like when I'm showing it of
course you know it worked out because
that's how chess is played you know I'm
not gonna show something that didn't
work out but it did work out but here
when you mix up your theory when you
play this move
you don't know if it's going to work out
and I had to remember or recall or
calculate whichever it is
um that I have to uh like win in that
position or something so
I saw all of that from there and yeah he
played Rook G8 actually which is
mentioned in the chat but the idea after
takes takes King F7 is I have this move
Knight G5
right I can give an ig5 check and after
Pawn takes I take the bishop
this this is common common tactic where
enemy King is
Knights check away right or Knight E5
also possible by the way and then I take
the bishop so this is cool interesting
smart the king D7 also another move
right which the queen protects h8 same
idea Knight E5 check
and then after Pawn takes I take
good easy
the final one the slightly tricky one
right my opponent can go King E7 he
doesn't have to run into any of the
checks
like a smart player would probably see
that King F7 King D7 runs into check and
queen G4 and my opponent is 2684 right
he was 27 plus
maybe one or two months ago before this
game so very respectable player
so what after King E7 though
my knight is still pinned
I cannot move it
I mean I can but my queen is hanging
and it's under attack so what do I do
now
the idea is not that different actually
some suggestion is unpin it with Bishop
E2 well you don't unpin it right
um you don't really unpin anything it
just takes it it's his move he's not
gonna let you have it Queen B3 is
actually quite interesting so the idea
is to give a check from here but
remember that
that
um even if I take it this way if you
give a check I can actually block what
the bishop if I really care
or what I can also do is take with the
pawn
and if you give me a check I can block
with this bishop so I'm not really
forced to like give up my Rook or
something
but yes
you guys are right you guys are correct
the move here is the move Knight E5 I
sacrifice
my queen and my knight both at the same
time if you take my knight we have seen
this idea I take your bishop and if you
take my queen
I play Knight takes C6 check
you have to move your king somewhere
I take your queen check
of The Rook takes
I take this with the king or with the
Rook
and then you go take my Pawn
and we play the game is as far as I
remember I'll check it again with the
computer the advantage is less than mine
plus one it used to be it's around plus
one
because white is up upon so it's it's
about plus one yeah it's 1.1
.8 so all that craziness happens and
then you get 0.7 up and up upon end game
where it's not that clear if you're
gonna win or not
this was frustrating to see but also my
opponents burning so much time like he's
calculating and calculating and he
doesn't know like what's happening and
what's going on and why would it be good
bad what is the best way to play Nobody
Knows of course after the game I check
with an engine it's it's clear I don't
know how many of you were here in the
last stream but
anyways so here my opponent played this
move Rook G8 but actually I was thinking
that
the best move from my opponent would be
castles
so let's see if any of you can guess the
move in this position he can Castle yeah
he can Castle it's legal
no no it's not illegal
it's legal
what do you mean illegal
that is very legal
anyways
so how do we play this position this
move
also has a story
so I can
our team
and um we're analyzing this game because
I'm super proud like it's like 2700
player and of course like it was a very
fancy game also so we're like talking
about it and I'm like but I wasn't sure
what he what would I play in this
position if my opponent um
canceled short
and then we discuss a bunch of moves
and my friend just suggests why don't
you play this move
and I'm like okay it's funny it's all
nice and everything but
it's not gonna work but then we'd look
at it and then we realized that yes that
was the best move so best move or one of
the fancy moves so let's see if anyone's
gonna guess this one
the reason I said I don't know if you
were here on the last one
it's kind of related actually so let's
see if anyone is gonna pick up the idea
probably not because I didn't give any
context of the previous stream
but yeah it's it's a nice move
I will give you guys I will give you
guys but okay some some players are
gonna get it because they might remember
but
I'm gonna give you guys some time to
guess make random guesses I I see many
guesses like Bishop H6 Knight G5 and uh
you can you can take your time and
continue guessing most
um C4 is another guess so there are
three guesses so far I see there is a
rook sack which I'm assuming it's
something like this or that I'm not sure
which one is the
referred one
I don't think uh it's it's easy to guess
this move
I mean okay many moves probably win here
but this move is a
if I had the chance to play it
I would play it if of course assuming I
saw it but I didn't need to see it to be
honest
Knight G5 no
I'm not even catching the idea of Knight
G5 to be honest Knight G5 what happens
if I take the queen
what's the point I don't understand it
because like I guess what you guys want
to do is sacrifice the rook and then
take the queen but you guys are sacking
way too much right you just sacked all
your pieces for what
you guys are giving up all my Pieces
Just because it's mine
doesn't mean that you can sacrifice
Bishop H3 is interesting Bishop H3 is
interesting but then my opponent is
going to take my knight right
so it's not that
Queen D2 is also very interesting so
you're trying to bring the queen into
the game
I think I I mean I'm pretty sure most of
the most suggested but are good but
yeah it's
it's not quite uh quite working it's an
interesting position
yeah I mean they might be working by the
way but the move I'm looking for is not
none of those like even if they're good
I want something completely different
from this position and I want somebody
to write it in the chat because I
honestly like it when someone finds the
move although they might have just
guessed it or just did like an educated
guess or they just randomly wrote all
the moves and it happened to be the best
move
okay yeah see so we have some people
understanding the point so how can we
try to get to this King we want the
queen on the H file this is what we want
we need this queen somewhere here and
actually we want it there
but for me to put the queen there I need
to get rid of my Bishop I need to get
rid of my king
so the move is actually
the crazy King D2 yeah
and it's okay who would who would
understand this move King D2 well King
D2 is super powerful because if you take
here now I go Bishop D3 I develop my
Bishop I want to go Queen H1 and I'm
actually completely winning yeah King D2
is not a human move but
it makes a lot of sense and after Bishop
takes F3 now I'm just gonna go Bishop E2
my point is to trade the Bishops and
after you take my Bishop
I take your Bishop back and my idea is
to play Rook a to H1 and my king is
perfectly safe and your king is
definitely not safe and this game is
probably going to end with uh
with King I mean with mate
King D2 or King E3 is your favorite move
so you saw the last stream or maybe you
went back to the last stream checked it
out and then came back and okay King D2
definitely a fun move right like I'm a
big fan of playing G4 and H4 but to be
honest King D2 might actually be my
favorite move maybe I should think about
it
um
maybe I should think about what's my
favorite move so yeah actually this is
definitely winning and I don't think
there is any other
lines here that I want to show yeah so
King D2 is is the win yeah
so my opponent played this move Rook G8
D3 King D2 that's my upcoming uh
repertoire now and then C3 King C2 and
it should be solid all right but what do
we do now so castles we understand King
D2 is genius and it wins somehow
but the game is far from over because
my opponent played Rook G8 and my knight
is still pinned and none of the fancy
Knight E5 Knight G5 none of that works
anymore
I can try to play Bishop H6 but then
my opponents might go Knight F5 so how
do I how do I get out of this
how do I get out of this
this guy's pinned
I'm not happy it's been
that night is
gone that's for sure
at least
it's kind of gone
yep
very good
Queen A4 for counter play exactly so I
wanna I wanna take this right if you
take my knight or something or maybe
take with the pawn it's not gonna matter
it's either way the same
I go Queen C6 check
you have to go again here
oh this is actually nice
I take on D5 I'm threatening mate
and the problem here is that for you to
stop the mate you either have to use
your queen or your Bishop If you defend
with the queen on the seventh rank
anywhere defending this guy your Rook
will hang
so your queen cannot defend both mate
and The Rook unless it goes to E8 but if
it goes to E8 then the bishop on D6 will
fall so the queen cannot defend without
losing The Rook or the bishop so the
queen has overloaded the other defense
you can make is Bishop back to E6 you
can attack my queen and stop the mate
which makes sense
so what do you do now
how do you proceed you need to make
something right you need to attack if
you go like take this Pawn you might
still win of course it makes sense but
there is even a better move
there is even a much better move here
absolutely Queen takes E6 recycle the
queen we are attacking all sorts of
pieces we don't want to keep any peace
on the board we're just sacking if he
takes
check
King age Bishop B5 check
Queen D7 I take the queen I take the
Knight I take everything and my opponent
has to resign because I took everything
and I'm up a bishop and I'll probably be
up more material soon
so
opponent cannot take my knight so what
do they do they play this move Rook C8
they defend their Pawn
and they're attacking my knight
foreign
the move Knight D2
in this position I had to rescue my
knight because
I could have tried to play Queen A7
threatening Checkmate but this would
have been a mistake because my
opponent's gonna go Rook C7 Defender
mate attack my queen and then win my
knight
so this is not possible my opponent
played the move I played Knight D2
and he played
Knight F5
okay now what
like the dust kind of settle like there
is no mate
Iris secured my knight
my opponent is kind of under attack
because
um he just played the Knight F5 move but
he's actually threatening much more than
that if I play a random move my opponent
wants to take my bishop and after I
recapture he wants to Checkmate me on G3
so but danger is actually real and
I need to take care of that somehow I
cannot just play
any random move that comes to my hand
and hope that I'm fine
yeah my opponent is threatening Knight
takes
so Bishop B5 is a suggestion which
actually is interesting I've never heard
I've never seen the suggestion before
actually
hmm
what about iGo 97 though it's
interesting move but what happens if I
play Knight E7 with the idea of taking
here and also maybe taking there
interesting suggestion never
like I've analyzed this game a couple of
times my life I never thought of Bishop
B5 it's very very interesting so Rook
sack but yeah you're sacrificing a bit
too much and I'm gonna take with the
king I don't see the mate
I don't see any mate here I think we
over sacrificed like here
there is definitely no mate here
I can take and just be fine I mean maybe
this is not the best way but like
the best move might be like Bishop E6 or
something right I'm just giving up too
much material
um
Bishop A6
interesting Bishop A6 Rook C7 maybe
right I can try to trade this Rook off
somehow and I'm still like building
pressure
Bishop E2 is a possibility yeah we don't
get mated if I play Bishop E2 but but
remember I'm not I'm not really the
player who like uh you know defends you
guys are thinking too defensive
but we have been sacrificing queens and
Rooks and like
Knights and everything and you guys are
telling me to like
back off and uh just
run away from opponent's threat if my
opponent makes a threat I I will run
away with it but I'm not gonna run away
with it like that right
yeah see see now now that I give you
guys hints you guys understand how it
should be done right now it takes E4
um another another Peace sacrifice which
is which is great but how does this work
or why does it work actually
so it's just free free piece right
what happens if my opponent takes that's
question number one what do you do
who even cares if you suck the Knight if
you do not have like any any backup to
it
how do we proceed
see if anyone has it
Queen A7 E5 E5 you mean D5
okay but
Queen C4 is a suggestion
they're trying to do this so I like I
like Queen C4
so Queen C4 your idea is Checkmate and
your idea is to take this Rook
and if your opponent goes something like
97
okay now we can take this Knight if you
take what the bishop or the queen your
Rook is hanging or at least I recover my
Rook
and if you take it with the king queen
F7 is Checkmate so we sacrifice even
more and more to Checkmate the opponent
great everything looks fantastic right
okay but I I will give you guys a
challenge what happens if my opponent
takes on E3
what do we do now
this should be calculated very
critically I would say because
if you make a slight mistake you might
actually end up losing the game
so
yes I'm slightly making it easier on all
of you by not making you calculate all
of this when I played Knight takes E4
without moving the pieces
but I'm just going to move it just to
make it easier so what do I do now well
what's the idea of black well the idea
is quite simple actually if I take
they're going to take and they're up at
night
and if I take to regain my material well
my king is under danger I can go to the
light squares I have to go to the dark
Square
Queen F2 check
well I cannot really go up there because
of mate
I mean it's going to be made
and I cannot go back
because you're just going to take all my
pieces and it's not going to be funny
anymore you can even take here
and I can try with some Last Hope to
threaten Checkmate but
I'll be the one getting checkmated first
so that's not good either
so what do I do
am I lost
I'm not lost of course I can take the
Knight
but then they take my knight
and this is another very key moment
how do we play with the white pieces
we're down a piece
we cannot Castle
because of this bishop I cannot Castle I
cannot put my king to safety
right I cannot do that
I'm clearly down a bishop my only hope
is to like Checkmate him maybe not only
hope but that's a good hope to have
but what do I play
how do I
try to get to this King
King D2 okay you guys you guys are
overdoing it vlogging no
not King did so I love the king D2
suggestion so whenever I stream you guys
are just gonna suggest King D2 from now
on which is which is fantastic it's
great to know that I I put this like
King D2 feeling in everyone but no King
D2 is not the move
Queen C4 is suggested Queen B3 is
suggested so what's the difference
what is the difference between these two
oops
I'll tell you there is a there is a big
difference one of them is good the other
one is bad there is a huge difference
actually
and it's up to the viewers to figure
that out but see the nuances like I have
to see all that when I'm playing an
actual game when I go Knight takes E4
otherwise I would just be giving up a
free night and then just hoping for the
best but once you are a GM you don't
really always want to hope for the best
sometimes you do
but
it's not an everyday thing
we we generally like to calculate and
make sure our moves make sense
so what do you do now
Queen B3 obviously why
why not Queen C4
why do we not want to go
Queen B3 you can go Queen B7
yes and no
that makes sense but yeah Royal Ford got
it that's exactly the more specific
reasoning Queen B3 is the best move
because if Queen C4
it would be Bishop G3 check King D2 and
then Queen D5 so what's the difference
because Queen D5 will just block the
mate and the diagonal but if I do this
with Queen B3 and if you give me a check
and go Queen D5 here I can play this
move Bishop C4
now I'm attacking your queen and
actually doing much more damage here
you can try to go Queen here
maybe some ideas with queen F2
so what do we do we want to stop our
opponent from playing what they want
Rook F1 we stopped that
and yes my opponent can take here but
then I would play this move Bishop F7
check
and I win the game
so that's not possible either
so what did my opponent do he saw this
and then he played this move Bishop back
to E7 he's like okay
I am not gonna
um let you do this to me I'm gonna
Retreat and I'm gonna attack your knight
on e4
now I'm threatening your knight
and I was like
are you sure you're threatening my
knight told him you can take it
if he takes it it's the same idea Queen
B3
exact same idea
and I'm trying to do that
or actually maybe even better not even
Queen B3 I can maybe even go Bishop C4
in this case
to try to get to his Rook because maybe
there's no maze but this one is for sure
good
so my opponent plays the move Queen B6
he's like I I actually I actually don't
want your knight your knight isn't going
to hang and I'm maybe gonna run away
from here somewhere right maybe maybe
I'll run away
okay I was like yeah you're right
by the way my opponent has like two
minutes or something I have like over
maybe 40 minutes 50 minutes whatever I
don't remember exactly like minute by
minute play but I have a lot of time he
has like maybe five minutes left or not
so what do I do
and this is how the London is supposed
to be that's why I'm showing this game
because I feel like London is super
underrated but if you play it like this
then London is super overrated it's too
strong
you know all right so we have some great
suggestions in the chat
B4 no not before B4 is too defensive
because yes my opponent is threatening
Queen B2 but it's uh it's against our
spirit you know to to defend against
their threats we defend only with active
play we don't want to defend with like
passive Retreats or stuff like that so
the move Rook takes E7 was suggested
which is a brilliancy though normally
what I do is of course you would have to
calculate this right you cannot just
play Rook E7 and then if I approve it's
all good there is so much happening
behind the scenes so if this Rook takes
E7 like in a real game you would
actually uh think about it a bit more
and another great suggestion by the way
which actually is the
the first move I looked at is this move
Queen A3
and it's like
it's amazing it's it's a fantastic move
but there is only a small flaw to it is
that my knight is hanging because it was
hanging this whole time but if my
Knight's not hanging my opponent cannot
take my queen because I go Knight takes
F6 check and if he goes there I go Rook
F7 mate
and if King goes to DA's then I go Rook
D7 mate so this alone
would have been
a fantastic game by itself but
Queen A3 unfortunately
does not do it because after Queen A3
D takes C4 and I
I resign doesn't work
another interesting move can be
something like Queen A6 but that's not
sufficient so what happens after Rook E7
okay now you can take with the Knight
but the problem to that is I can go
Knight F6 and then take the bishop or
The Rook or whatever I feel like but I
have at least two pieces so he has to
take out the king okay now what how do
we how do we proceed
how do I make use of this attack my
knight is under attack I need to do
something about it
and it's not as straightforward as we
want it to be
Queen A3 again okay Queen A3 makes sense
the idea is that if the King goes
anywhere I'm gonna take here right so
what my opponent can play is the move C5
and now what do I do I can take it with
the Knight I can take it with the pawn I
can do other things too so what do I do
again I have plenty of time on the clock
and my opponent is like
in second I thought I as far as I
remember he had like a minute or
something my opponent had maybe a little
bit over a minute or something
but definitely not more maybe two
minutes
I'm not sure though somebody might have
to check the the broadcast
from the day
so I was super tempted actually with
with one move
and I kept on trying to make it work
yeah I was I was tempted to go DC right
this is what I was calculating the whole
time with the idea if something like
Queen C6
I can play like Bishop B5
and I was like stuck with this thing
and um there's quite a lot maybe
happening
um but yeah there is King d8 at the end
and there's nothing
so I'm thinking and thinking and here
even like Knight D6 is good you know
it's not like mate or anything but it's
still winning
but then what I realized is after dc5 my
opponent can play this McQueen E6
pinning my knight
and um
it's annoying it's annoying because I
don't know how to like
continue I can give a check
but
I don't think this leads to anything if
he goes simply like King E8 or something
and I don't see the way forward like yes
I'm super close yes it's almost made and
I'm like almost winning but almost is
not unfortunately enough like we have to
either be winning or not winning it's
there is nothing in the middle in this
situation because I'm down in exchange
I'm gonna be down a night very soon I
mean down in Rook very soon because I'm
losing the night
and nothing is probably Gonna Save Me
here so
what I ended up doing which is actually
the correct decision I played this move
Knight takes C5
and my opponents reaction was very
natural because I'm threatening all
sorts of discoveries right
trying to pick up this queen so he
played the move King d8
okay
so how do we play now
what do we do
how do we proceed
this is a key position
we're down something
we're down what exchange yeah
but I have some Pawns in return so
materially I'm doing great
material wise I'm doing very well
but
It's Not Over
opponent is still fighting and they
actually are putting decent resistance
although they have almost no time
and how how do we play in this position
yeah I remember I spent decent amount of
time here
to understand what I should do because I
if you have time honestly you should
calculate you should spend a lot of time
understanding what's what is happening
because it's not as simple as it looks
like
[Music]
um
Knight B7 if Queen takes you can pin
you could try
but again you're giving up a knight
and then the bishop in order to get a
rook that's not a good exchange for you
you don't want to do that
the suggestion is this
that to pick up that Rook but this Rook
is useless when you compare it to this
beautiful Knight on C5 you don't want to
just give this Knight up to get that
rook and you're giving up this bishop
too so I can go something like Queen E7
check
I can force the Queens off
and then after you take my Rook I can
take it back with something doesn't
matter with what and then I'm going to
take this guy
and you just gave up a lot of pieces
so that's not good
maybe giving up the Rook for the night
would have been a better chance so the
suggestion is maybe this was better for
him it could have been a good move but
what's your idea after I go dc5 I'm
attacking your queen
you have to go somewhere right say you
give a check or something then I just
run out of the check and I'm gonna go
rookie one next so your queen is very
exposed
and this is not going to help you if you
go Queen E4 or something trying to look
for counter play Ricky one is going to
shut everything down so you're not gonna
be able to defend so The Rook sack would
not be enough actually
King d8 is probably the most logical
move to get out of everything
okay so what do we do now
what do we play now
now that we're in this
I know you're good
GM title is not that easy to get F3 King
F2 interesting media so you want to
sacrifice some stuff
interesting I have three
kind of takes King F2
Bishop A6 is another suggestion which is
which definitely is a possibility I do
remember looking at this actually
let me let me see let me try to remember
what I was thinking here
Bishop A6
this is probably a good move too
this is probably a good move too
what happens if I go like Rook C6
you want to go Knight B7
it should be five but what's the idea of
Bishop B5 isn't it a free Bishop
can I not I know you suggested it
multiple times isn't this free am I
missing something
to me this looks like a free Bishop
Maybe I'm Wrong
or Bishop B5 at a different moment maybe
because this is completely free
it should be seven
oh what
Oh you mean after Rook C6 Bishop B7
that's a different story Bishop B5 alone
is a different story
so two different suggestions Bishop A6
to
B7 versus Bishop B5
which I think Bishop A6 is interesting
let's actually check it with the engine
what it says it's winning Bishop A6 is
completely winning it's plus four
Bishop B5 is definitely
not it's losing so Bishop A6 would have
won the game
but of course the viewers know me right
the move
the move I played is probably something
you guys can guess if I told you that
it's my favorite move I think everyone's
gonna just type it in the chat
immediately after after seeing so many
games
with this move everyone's gonna be like
aha okay now we know what he played
so yeah you guys are right I want to
improve this Rook right I want to bring
the Rook into the game and the whole
left three King F2 suggestion or like
the bishop out suggestion okay I don't
actually need the bishop out for the
Rook on A1 to come to the game so I did
play this move King D2 my idea is just
bring the Rook over
to E1
and just play
like just improve my Rook on A1 that's
not doing anything
and um
yeah
so my opponent played the move Knight H4
it's a very logical move he's
threatening to take my opponent G6 but
he's also threatening to play the move
Knight F3 check which will be
maybe painful if I'm not careful enough
looks like Paul Murphy playing yeah
that's kind of uh
that's kind of the point I would say
like I like to play chess from that era
type of stuff
because I like this type of
improvising and tactical and creative
stuff here I played the move Bishop D3
you know just call developing my Bishop
if Knight F3 I'm gonna go King C2
exactly my king is going to be super
safe there is no Bishop F5 or anything
so I'm just making sure my king is safe
first and I don't want to play rookie
one because he has Knight F3 oops not
Bishop F3 Knight after so maybe I'm
actually threatening this move Rook H1
and then try to go from here
right
so my opponent plays Knight takes G6 and
I actually don't want any counter play
I just get rid of that Bishop he takes
back and I play rookie one
I am all out for my opponent's king
and trying to create something from this
position
I mean there are definitely other ways
to play this position but I thought
Bishop D3 bring the Rook make it simple
Knight G6 is attacking the bishop on F4
so I make sure that I don't fall for
anything
I take it and then rookie one and when
you think about it all my pieces are
active they are participating and this
guy was not participating but now it is
participating so I have achieved a lot
um
I'm down an exchange but I have two
pawns for it so I have a lot of material
too material is definitely even but my
king is much more safer compared to like
my enemy King so
we are happy and in this position
my opponent played the move Rook G8
they are sort of trying to defend their
back rank in this position
which
definitely is a good attempt
but it's not
it's not something you want to play at
least it definitely feels like a
desperate attempt to like I don't know
play something like rookie or something
why not Rook C6 Rook C6 definitely could
have been
could have been a move
I'm trying to sort of
stop maybe 96 or something
but this loses too it actually loses on
the spot
because I have this move Knight B7 check
so he was covering this square and if
you take it with the queen
I go Queen f8 check
your king cannot go there because my
Bishop is guarding it your king cannot
step on the E file it has to go up and
here rookie seven is made
so maybe that's just that's just the
fancier one but there is also Queen E8
mate multiple nates
so you don't have to take my Knights you
can definitely go here try to escape but
now I have this Rook E8 check
if you go to D7 I have Queen E7 mate
and if you take your Rook B8
Checkmate as well so mating with the
Rook
all the time almost
so my opponent played the move
Rook G8 to guard the f8 square but now
this Rook no longer guards another
critical Square actually in the position
it doesn't guard this Square on F6
and you might be like what why does F6
play any role in this position
um E7 is not guarded but there is no
immediate access to E7 but the critical
Square actually is the square F6
and the idea is that I go Knight B7
check here
if you take it with the queen
I go Queen D6 check
you cannot step on the e-file once again
and after Queen blocks with the D7 I
told you this F6 Square was weak I take
you cannot Escape
because I'm protecting everything you
have to block with the queen and then
this is mate
so here what happened after Rook G8
Knight B7 we established that you cannot
take it my opponent played the move
King up to D7
and I played my my Rook just was on A1
now it's on E7 in two moves I didn't
have to make plenty of moves with this
Rook The Rook joined the party King C6
and here
how do you end the game I'll ask the
viewers it's the last movie of the game
and my opponent resigned after this
what do we do
Bishop D6 no
you gotta be
Rook joined the match in overtime and
score the goal basically yeah everything
was played and then yep Queen A4 check
Knight A5 is good too but Queen A4
and my opponent resigned
because he has to block with Queen A5 I
would have played Queen B5 sorry I would
have played Knight A5 King B6 Rogue B7
check King A6 Queen B5 it would have
been mate but after Queen A4 my opponent
was like okay I had enough and
um that was it that was game and yeah
this is definitely one of the best games
I've played
in my chess career definitely the best
game I played in the London and I think
this is the only game I will have time
for because it was such a long and
fighting and crazy game but I do have
more London Games which I probably will
show on
on Thursday
um
hopefully
so yeah I thought this would be super
entertaining because although I've
analyzed it several times I've never
done it in like a very
crowded scenery so hopefully you guys
enjoyed it
um it was a lot of fun playing it and
also analyzing it definitely there are
other key moments which I might have
missed but
I just want to go back to this moment
where we talked about
castles meeting it with King D2 this is
probably the highlight of the game you
can remember the rest is like
fun too but this was if this had been
played I think it would have been
brilliancy and let me actually see if
the leeches computer suggests King D2 it
probably will not so let's see
it doesn't see it so my computer
currently says Bishop H6 plus 2.2 and
any other move is not good but as far as
I remember I analyzed it with the
computer later it did give King D2 so
let me make them move King D2 so it
gives zeros
and it's confused now it's plus 2.4 and
it will probably take over from there
and it's way more than that now it's
plus three so it's it I think is the
best move but it fails to see it so
it's just not not deep enough for the
engine to understand but it's okay it's
it's fine they don't have to understand
the depth of King D2 but with a strong
engine you can always verify that King
D2 is the best move
so
all right everyone
thank you for watching the stream
hopefully you learned something
hopefully you were entertained and maybe
you will you will play this line with
the with the G4 variations maybe you'll
play this line one day and uh
remember this game but until next time
people take care and uh have a good
night
[Music]